[Music]
hi i'm aparna sinha welcome to day two
of google cloud next i'll be co-hosting
today alongside ores holdslay and we've
got a really great lineup of new
technology and demos from google cloud
but before we get started i want to
thank you all for taking time out of
your busy week to be here with us
yesterday was an incredible first day at
next thomas and sundar made some amazing
announcements
this week
we're releasing over 100 new products
services and programs for you
we're kicking off day two now with this
keynote a cloud built for developers
after this we'll jump right into a live
developer q a where you can ask us
anything
and then tomorrow is community day and
that'll be totally dedicated to you for
learning discussions networking and all
kinds of fun
all right
let's get things started by welcoming
oars
hi orrs hi aparna hi everyone
i hope you're as excited as i am to get
started today and since this is a
developer keynote we'll kick it off with
our first demo right away from google
research and our deepmind colleagues
who've been working on some amazing
voice technology
welcome to next 21 documents
foreign
now before you get too impressed by my
language skills i did not actually speak
these words
what you just heard is a custom
text-to-speech model that has trained on
my voice and that can generate synthetic
speech in different languages
and our teams have already started using
this technology to improve our voice
experience for all users that's right
google's project euphonia is already
using custom voice to help people with
atypical speech to communicate and be
better understood
technology like this creates a more
inclusive world
to find out more about this check out
the project euphonia website
custom voice is available today for
select cloud customers we're very
mindful of the potential misuses of this
technology and we're taking great care
to prevent them by reviewing each use
case uniquely
now look around you
every day you see innovation that's
brought to you
by developers like yourself with
persistence and skill
and google has a long tradition of
supporting developers in open source and
elsewhere uh for years uh you've been
using technologies like kubernetes
firebase tensorflow
go angular grpc many others
and when we built google cloud we built
it for developers and we were inspired
by all the things you've created with it
and our job is quite simply to make it
easier for you to do what you love
so we focus
on making you as productive as
productive as possible with
the least amount of effort and so in
everything we design
we take all the feedback that you're
sharing with us and
uh build a cloud platform that just
works
uh whether that's by natively embedding
key security or sustainability features
into the platform itself or by feature
featuring partner solutions uh right
within our own console we're really
focused on one goal giving you the best
developer experience
of any cloud provider
google cloud has had tremendous traction
with digital native customers since our
very early days
how have you seen customer and partner
adoption evolve since then
well many of our biggest customers are
cloud natives but we've seen tremendous
adoption by a broad segment of
enterprise customers in traditional
industries as well like entertainment or
financial services for example
major league baseball
which is north america's oldest and most
attended professional sports league is
using google cloud to modernize fan
engagement and to increase operational
efficiency
and equifax which was founded in 1899
and is one of the world's largest
consumer credit reporting agencies
is transforming itself from a credit
bureau to a next-generation data
analytics and technology company built
on google cloud
we've seen a huge shift
essentially every company is becoming a
tech company to increase their
competitiveness and establish leadership
in their industries
developer talent and cloud services are
at the heart of this shift
whether you call that digital
transformation or something else
companies of all sizes are finding that
google cloud is optimized to help make
your data your applications and your
talent more useful and relevant to your
business
exactly and as thomas mentioned
yesterday everyone needs to be thinking
through how they'll fundamentally shift
into a technology company to serve their
customers in the most meaningful ways 10
years from now
and you as developers are key to making
this happen
so organizations ask themselves
do we have
the most cutting edge technology to
become a leader in our industry and you
the developers are well equipped to
answer this
and we are super focused uh on making
you and your company successful and
there's two areas we focus on to support
your growth first of course making it
easier for developers to get their job
done
second
investing in the developer community so
that everyone can learn and grow from
each other
so let's talk about how google cloud is
making it easier for developers to get
their job done
um from our transformational
infrastructure stack to our deep
innovations in data security ml
every feature we release starts with
simplifying the developer experience uh
take our open cloud experience for for
example we recently expanded our compute
stack
to include tau vms that deliver 42
percent better price performance over
any other comparable solution in the
market with no recompile
and thanks to our zero trust approach to
security google cloud was ranked a
leader in ios platform native security
by forrester well ahead of the
competition
and of course we're focusing also on
managed services that make it easy for
you to deploy scale and manage
kubernetes clusters
on the edge or in the cloud and google
cloud has the most complete and most
secure container experience for
developers in fact the 2021 gartner
solution scorecard for google kubernetes
engine gave gke an overall score of 92
again well ahead of the competition
and of course with gke and anthos you
can run these containers anywhere on
premise other clouds on the edge you
know anywhere
so it's fair to say that in the years
since google invented kubernetes
containers have really completely
revolutionized it operations
now recently european filmmakers from
honeypot.io created the documentary on
the history of kubernetes and it will be
out in january 2022 and you are the very
first audience to have a look at the
trailer right now so let's roll that
sounds pretty awesome do i look at you
look at cameron
[Music]
2013 it was clear that cloud was a thing
but most folks were focused on
infrastructure cloud
the dirty secret for a long time is like
you know people who are either building
their own data centers using colos
there's a huge resource waste
and so at that point
automation tools are all the rave people
are now trying to abstract the way the
servers google was looking for ways to
apply its internal infrastructure
expertise
to the cloud
as we started looking at technologies
like docker we were like impressed by
the strength of what they'd accomplished
in solving a very specific problem
this is going to happen with us or
without us google had to make a bold
move in the cloud space to be the
long-term winner every big startup i
felt like had a container orchestration
project and half of them were announced
at dockercon 2014. open source is most
successful when it's played as a
positive sum game
[Music]
this is such a great community
yeah absolutely i recognize a lot of the
faces and i can't wait to see the film
uh now let's get back to uh how we're
making it easier for developers uh
for you to build really the leading
technology companies of tomorrow
now kubernetes deployments can involve a
fair bit of manual configuration uh
clusters nodes load balancers yamls etc
but not on google cloud because we offer
you the most automated and secure
kubernetes experience available
um with gke autopilot google provisions
and manages the cluster's entire
underlying infrastructure including
control plane node pools or
working nodes and they
that lets you focus on the higher level
services and applications that you're
building
nobody else
offers anything like this
because beyond managing node upgrades gk
autopilot also automatically configures
security features like sheila gk nodes
secure boot and workload identity and it
also implements security best practices
by blocking let's say features like
external ips or legacy authorization
so
you don't get a toy kubernetes cluster
with gke autopilot you get a
sophisticated cluster that uses the best
practices brought to you by the team
that brought to you kubernetes itself
so you're always up to date
and you get the same results as the
experts without having to be an expert
yourself
the pandemic put developers in the
driver's seat and you all drove gka
usage to all-time highs
at the same time we saw explosive growth
in the use of google cloud serverless
offerings especially cloud run and cloud
functions
it's mainly enterprise developers who
have driven this growth
cloud run excels at developer experience
it's earned the highest customer
satisfaction rating among developers as
measured by user research
international cloud run combines the
best of both worlds bringing you
serverless and containers there's no
cluster to set up or configure so
developers are able to scale seamlessly
and securely
under the hood cloudrun scales container
instances in isolated sandboxes any
access outside a sandbox is mediated by
network controls or identity and access
management or both
and it isn't just for new apps
cloudrun supports traditional workloads
like java spring boot and asp.net
we also recently introduced committed
use discounts to lower the cost at scale
and we've introduced always-on cpu which
enables asynchronous and background
processes to be used on cloud run
so you have all the benefits of
serverless without the restrictions
the theme here is easier more secure
development
especially with remote work
you're absolutely right uh we've been
focusing on remote development for some
time now but the pandemic has certainly
accelerated the shift now what would be
more essential to remote development
than to be able to use the full power of
gcp
right from your laptop with zero local
setup
cloud shell editor is a context aware
remote development environment that lets
you develop and manage applications
securely from any browser it supports
languages like go java node python
c-sharp and it comes with an integrated
debugger source control api explorer
and if you want to test locally on your
laptop it also comes with local
emulators for kubernetes and serverless
apis thanks oars next let me introduce
you to abby kerry she's going to show us
how google cloud makes it easy for you
to securely build modern applications
again right from your laptop hi abby hi
farna
we developers have had a hard time
writing extending deploying and
operating applications but doesn't have
to be difficult let's start with cloud
shell editor it comes with current
versions of your favorite dev tools like
docker mini cube scaffold and more
there's nothing to download or install
locally
tutorials are built into cloud shell
editor which makes it easy to come up to
speed on complex topics like gke
so no more switching between tabs docs
your terminal and your code
this integrated experience is highly
differentiated from other clouds you can
even author your own tutorials and that
allows your organization to share best
practices and onboard new hires faster
another popular feature is kubernetes
yaml authoring assistance
let's say i want to add yaml for a
service to this project i can press
control space and then find the
kubernetes service snippet
now i can tab through and fill
everything in
i also get auto-completes
and if i happen to make a formatting
mistake i am notified that there's an
issue in real time
now many of you prefer to work locally
in an ide this same yaml authoring
assistance it's also available for vs
code and intellij via the cloud code
plugin
cloud code has built-in support for both
cloud run and kubernetes
in fact if you're using cloud run or
functions you don't need to know docker
you can build and deploy your app with
just one command because cloud code or
cause cod build is integrated under the
hood
this is an application with no docker
file
with the new gcloud run deploy command
all i have to do is provide a name for
my service
and then let it know where my source
code lives which is this current
directory
and we're deploying
so nice
and thanks to this ease of use 98 of
users deploy an application to cloud run
on their first try in less than five
minutes
i just showed source code deploys the
cloud run but there are more ways google
cloud has made deployment easier and
more secure
first i can scan my build container
images to check for vulnerabilities
i've already run an on-demand scan on
one of my images using gcloud artifacts
docker images scan
now i can copy the id of my scan
and then view my image's vulnerabilities
with the list vulnerabilities command
and then once that's finished a severity
level is assigned to each vulnerability
to help you prioritize that's super
important it's really helpful in
addressing security concerns earlier in
the software development life cycle
but now what if your build pipeline is
compromised for that i can enable binary
authorization on my deployed cloud run
services this way only trusted container
images are deployed to production
binary authorization is truly unique in
the industry it enables you to put
proactive security measures in place to
reduce software supply chain attack risk
by blocking deployments that violate
policy
and speaking of deploying we're making
it seamless for you to do ci cd securely
you can take advantage of serverless
build environments within your own
private network with cloud build private
pools
and for advanced cd we have google cloud
deploy which allows you to create custom
delivery pipelines for your specific use
case and needs that is so cool
well a real application connects to many
supporting cloud services so abby can
you show us an example of how we make
these integrations easier sure when
creating a cloud function it's easy to
integrate with seeker manager
first
create a secret that stores your api key
which i've already done
now i can either mount it as a volume or
expose it as an environment variable
i'll mount it as a volume and then i'll
name my mount path
this will always point to the latest
version of my secret
and now i can securely reference this
api key from my source code this
abstraction enables portability and a
better local development experience
cloudrun also integrates with seeker
manager
to make it easier to do the right thing
and not put sensitive data in source
love that so much okay so now you've
written your app you've deployed your
app and you've connected your app to
other google cloud resources what's next
operating your app in production
with cloud ops you get one integrated
view for your alerts
events
metrics
and logs
no more jumping around multiple tools as
you try to understand what went wrong
that was so awesome abby thank you for
sharing this with us thanks aparna
in each of these instances we've done
the integration work for you because the
more work we put into this the less work
you have to do
and this principle applies to security
as well we've put a lot of energy into
building security natively into
everything we do so that you can
innovate with assurance
both dke and cloud run benefit from the
security fixes we implement before
vulnerabilities are exposed just think
about the famous vulnerability uncovered
in how kubernetes was handling proxy
requests
we found it we coordinated and
communicated the disclosure we fixed it
for the entire kubernetes community and
we patched all our products before any
customers were impacted
more recently cyber threats have shifted
the focus towards the software supply
chain
that's right
malicious actors are trying to
compromise the software supply chain
from bad code submission to bypassing
the ci cd pipeline altogether and to
help solve this problems we proposed an
industry standard
called salsa it's a security framework
that provides common criteria for
increasing levels of software security
through automation and through
cryptographic signing at each stage of
the software supply chain
and that makes it uh
possible but not necessarily easy and so
making it easy for developers to ensure
security is super important and that's
why we're focusing on building the
security right into the developer tool
chain anticipating and preventing issues
ahead of time
not when you're most at risk so for
example cloud build our service that
lets you build test and deploy across
multiple environments such as vms
serverless kubernetes or firebase now
offers salsa level one compliance by
default
because cloud build gives you verifiable
build prominence so this provenance lets
you trace a binary to the source code
that it was built from to prevent
tampering and to prove that the code
that you think you're running actually
is the code you are running
cloud build is the first and only ci cd
service to offer this capability but we
go beyond that as you've seen build
integrity uh
automatically generates digital
signatures which can then be validated
before deployment by binary
authorization that's another google
cloud first
and so without you needing to do
anything
we prevent anyone in your organization
from deploying code that has not been
built by your legitimate build system
now ensuring security post-deployment is
equally critical on gcp you can enable
continuous scanning and you can use our
service mesh to embrace a zero trust
security model and automatically and
declaratively secure your services and
the communication so you can manage
authentication authorization and
encryption between services with little
or no changes to the applications
themselves
let me say that again
with little to no changes to the
applications themselves
so that means that these security
improvements help secure not just new
code but also existing binaries so you
can use them for any application that
you're migrating to the cloud
both and service mesh and now cloud
build hybrid are available across google
cloud and your on-premise environment
and they work with
vpc service controls and vpg peering to
automate the developer security for your
enterprise
no other cloud provider protects your
software supply chain to this level
because
we started working on software supply
chain security long before it was in
headlines
and so by choosing tcp you benefit from
this leading edge focus on security
whether we're building foundational open
source technologies like kubernetes or
istio or turning them into fully managed
services like gke and antho service mesh
our goal is always to reduce complexity
for our users
by helping create these industry
standards we can provide safer and
simpler services for you the developer
and that's exactly our approach to
securing the software supply chain we've
co-founded the open source security
foundation with other technology leaders
to create security standards for open
source software
and we're starting to bring products to
market like open source insights which
provides you a complete transitive
dependency graph for many open source
packages
now let's turn back to orrs to hear why
google cloud is best positioned to
support you in becoming a technology
leader in your industry using data as a
core asset
thanks yeah so far we've been talking
about developing and managing code
but data is at the heart of many
enterprises
so we also have the leading data cloud
products in the industry
designed for optimal performance and
reliability for applications of all
sizes while scaling to immense
escape capacity um
now
let's start with databases when it comes
to databases every cloud qc choices uh
they offer sql databases which are great
but unfortunately don't scale
and of course nosql databases which do
scale but unfortunately are not sql
only google cloud gives you a third
choice with spanner
because spanner is sql and in fact it
just got a postgres interface
but it scales horizontally and it can
literally handle a billion requests per
second
nobody else has a scalable sql system so
it's no wonder we're seeing huge
adoption
now on the data warehouse side we have
of course the leading cloud data
warehouse with bigquery hundreds of
customers are using bigquery at petabyte
scale today petabyte
each and you can run of course bigquery
omni on aws or azure
on top of that open source systems for
data lake processing like flank spark
and beam run natively on google cloud in
a simpler and more cost effective way
than in other environments uh in fact
you can realize a 57 lower tcl compared
to on-premise data leaks for data
science projects
now on top of that savings our data
cloud also includes the world's first
and only auto scaling and serverless
spark service
and finally google has deep partnerships
with leading data-driven companies
including databricks confluent mongodb
radius labs and many others
and so together we help customers access
an open platform that powers analytics
at scale yet is easy to use
our partner community is central to the
health of our cloud business
and we're especially excited about the
innovation coming from our data cloud
partnerships
together we've optimized our
infrastructure for performance and
efficiency to give our partners that
extra edge when they run on google cloud
one of our leading data partners is
mongodb
and we have their ceo dave iteria here
with us today
welcome dave
hi everyone happy to be here
dave one of the trends we're seeing in
our enterprise customer base is that
they are now competing for leadership
positions in their industry by becoming
technology companies
how would you say
google cloud and mongodb working
together can help these customers
achieve that transition
well aparna the companies who are in the
leadership positions in their industries
are those who have built their
competitive advantage using software and
data to transform their business
and the key word here is build you can't
buy a competitive advantage you have to
build it this means you need to enable
your developers to innovate as quickly
as possible whether it's building new
software to seize new opportunities or
to respond to new threats
mongodb and google cloud deeply
understand this developers choose
mongodb on google cloud because we give
them the tools they need to be as
productive as possible including having
our services available in the google
cloud console for easy discovery and
deployment today mongodb atlas runs in
24 google regions across the world with
deep technical integrations with
google's analytic and ai tools
this enables our customers to innovate
quickly and emerge as leaders in their
industries
as a result we're seeing explosive
growth of customers embracing the true
value of our partnership
that's incredible
so when you think about the development
teams at these new customers what's the
biggest challenge that you're helping
them solve
yeah when you talk to development teams
you find that they spend the most amount
of their time trying to work with data
as serving relevant data at the right
time to the right audience is critical
to building any application
unfortunately
relational databases are not designed
for the way developers think or code nor
are they designed for scale fault
tolerance
or
resilience consequently development
teams find it hard to move fast using
relational databases
mongodb is designed to address this
problem we make it very easy for
developers to work with data and we're
able to address the most demanding
requirements for performance scale and
fault tolerance
the partnership with mongodb and google
cloud enables developers around the
world to easily build modern software
applications to address their needs of
today and tomorrow
that's terrific thank you so much for
being here with us today
thank you for having me
and yes thanks dave for joining us um
now there's lots of ways developers can
improve their productivity
automate tasks that are repetitive
master the command line use the best
tools that make your life easier or
reuse other people's code you know just
to name a few and another great way to
accelerate your productivity is with
building blocks or templates or fully
managed services in areas like machine
learning
because on google cloud you don't have
to be an expert to build smart
applications
with new services like vertex ai you can
build deploy and scale more effective ai
models quickly
so that lets you deliver the insights to
your organization that will help them
create more personalized customer
experiences
run more efficient processes and take
that leadership position in your
industry
so with that let's go to our next live
demo
joining me today is anusha vastava she's
going to show us how these breakthroughs
in ai are advancing cloud adoption and
redefining the world of document
processing hi anu hey aparna
we all know how to work with data when
it's in a structured format like in a
database some json csv files or just
variables in my code right
but what about unstructured data
many of the world's business processes
start include or end with a document but
these documents can be difficult to
process
think about all the ways you could
enhance your application if you could
just unlock that data
this is where google cloud document ai
comes in
doc ai is a platform that has solutions
and tooling for automating your
workflows backed by machine learning
we've bundled together some of google's
flagship ai technology such as computer
vision ocr natural language
understanding and even google's
expertise and building knowledge graphs
all to provide you with a simple
yet powerful way to build applications
that better understand unstructured data
let's go see a demo of doc ai in action
so here we have a receipt i was buying
some office supplies since we are
unfortunately not back in the office yet
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
actually upload this into the doc ai
platform
so in our cloud console we have the
docker platform where we have built-in
preview mechanisms so you can test out
your documents
so this is going to an endpoint which
has a specialized model we have
specifically trained on a variety of
expenses
google maintains and improves the models
for you
wait a minute
i hope this is not with my data
absolutely not we never use your data to
train our models your data is only used
to serve your request
so let's take a look at the data
extracted
i've seen this before next you're going
to tell me that you're going to automate
my expenses
i knew you would say that this is the
canonical demo use case right but have
you ever seen it like this
take a look at this field that i'm
highlighting the supplier address
this address isn't present anywhere in
the document wow where did that come
from this is only possible with google's
document ai the secret sauce here is
that the knowledge graph is able to not
only give you back the original text
from document but it's going to enrich
your response akin to what you'd see in
a search but as part of your api
response wow that's really great
and it's not just this we have several
specialized models for many more
document types of much higher complexity
let's take a look at this payslip so i
ran this earlier
and we're looking at the preview output
again you can see that we have some keys
we have some fields you can see
enrichment on the employer name and the
address
once your data is in a schematized
format meaning that we know for every
document of a certain doctype there are
common important pieces of information
so what we did is we predefined a set of
keys so what we do is with your
extracted data we merge your data to
these predefined keys so it's much
easier to work with than raw ocr
so
once it's in a schematized format it's
easier to pass on to a downstream
service or maybe you're using something
for analytics like bigquery or looker
that makes sense but what about ensuring
accuracy and also do you have
multi-language support we know that with
important documents such as these you
can't afford any missteps when it comes
to accuracy so that's why
doc ai provides a human in the loop
configuration to trigger on confidence
scores so either for specific keys or on
the entire document itself and as for
translation we support over 100
languages such as spanish japanese
arabic no other solution on the market
supports such a wide array of languages
human in the loop translation and
knowledge graph capabilities that can be
applied to a wide variety of documents
this seems super useful
of course the next big question is can
it be applied to big bulky complex
documents like like business contracts
let's take a look
so here i read a contract earlier this
morning
you can see that there are typical
things you'd find in any contract
there's some
document names the parties involved some
dates and like with every easy to read
contract being sarcastic here
there is an expiration term so this
expiration date actually isn't present
anywhere in the document and it's
actually not easy to figure out it's not
in an easily parcelable format shocker
google's contract processor is able to
figure out this state value by
understanding signals found across the
entire document
wow
well anu before you go can you tell our
awesome developers how they can get
started with doc ai absolutely so i know
we covered a lot at just breakneck
speeds so check out the breakout
sessions on dock ai to dive deeper you
can also
check out the documentation for code
labs and quick starts we have client
libraries and all of your favorite
languages such as python node.js my
personal favorite is java but it's an
api so you can really use this with
whatever platform or framework you're
already using
we are thrilled and look forward to see
how you use google doc ai to power your
applications
that was amazing can i have a high five
yeah thank you anu i loved every part of
it thank you for having me
another area that google has invested in
deeply and that's becoming more
important to more companies is
sustainability
many cloud providers have a vision for
us in sustainable future and many aim to
have uh to match their electricity
consumption with 100 renewable energy by
2025 or 2030.
we accomplished 100 renewable energy in
2017 so we're the only hyperscale cloud
to do this today
and all that with data centers that are
twice as efficient as the average data
center
this past week sunder talked about
google's goal to enable over a billion
users to live and work more sustainably
by next year
to reach goals like this and those
outlined in climate pledges made by more
organizations every day we rely on
developers like you to do something
about it
but we also know that it's difficult
that's right one of the biggest
challenges that companies face is that
they lack the tools to account for
environmental costs and to help
developers address this for their
organizations we built sustainability
tools directly into google cloud
with a google cloud carbon footprint you
have access to the energy related
emissions data that you need for
external carbon disclosures in just one
click
now you won't need this calculator if
you just want to report the net carbon
footprint of your workload on tcp
because on gcp it's always zero
we also have our region picker where you
can choose the data center region with
the lowest gross carbon cost right now
of course again your net impact is zero
no matter what region you pick but this
tool lets you help go one step further
to become carbon free not just carbon
neutral
now that's actually a tool that i can't
wait to deprecate in 2030 or so because
google cloud has committed to be 100
carbon free by 2030 every hour of every
day
now we also realize there's still a lot
to learn when it comes to building
sustainably and to help we just released
a master class called sustainable i.t
decoded
with some of the world's top experts so
check it out for guidance on how we can
all build more sustainably
now while we're proud to run the
cleanest cloud in the industry were even
more inspired by the work that our
customers are doing with google cloud to
solve climate change challenges that are
unique to their business
and today we bring you a preview of
google earth engine and its integration
with google cloud
with over 700 data sets and 50 petabytes
of data today
earth engine gives scientists and
developers access to the world's largest
catalog of satellite imagery and to
tools for driving sustainable impact
so let's look at this in a bit more
detail with an example of how google
earth engine and google cloud enable
customers to assess risks arising from
climate change
but instead of me telling you about it
we've invited joel conkling to show you
thanks saperna the world is constantly
changing and that creates opportunities
and risks
helping uncover critical insights about
the changing world is why we're
integrating earth engine into google
cloud now integration is now in private
preview
today i'll demo a workflow that combines
vertex ai
earth engine
bigquery and google maps platform
to show how google cloud makes it
incredibly easy for you to innovate and
deliver insights and do it quickly
so here's a scenario
you work at an insurance company and you
need to analyze your company's exposure
to flood risk you think new buildings
may be a strong contributor to that risk
and you want to test your hypothesis
to do that we first need to understand
where the built environment is expanding
in other words we just need to
categorize the surface of the entire
planet
that could be hard but vertex ai offers
the tooling to develop a best-in-class
ml model
and earth engine provides constantly
updated data
let's fast forward a bit we finished
training our model
and now earth engine is sending
satellite imagery to be categorized so
your understanding of the world can
update in near real time
here's the earth engine script showing
the results of that model this area in
red
is where the model estimates the
locations of buildings that's your
current built environment
to find the change over time
we need a few more lines of code
these lines of code give us a built
environment in 2016.
and here
we calculate the difference between 2016
and today
when there's a change it shows up in
purple
on the map
this is where there are new buildings
so next we're going to export sample and
export the data so we can do additional
analysis in bigquery
over in the bigquery console this script
clusters those data points
here
and then outputs polygons that show the
areas with the biggest changes in the
built environment
so at this point you have a few options
you could combine this data with flood
locations you identify around the world
also with earth engine
maybe you want to enhance your model
with weather data and physical terrain
data
bats available in earth engine too
you could also include data on your
company's insurance portfolio to gain
additional insight into critical risks
we'll wrap up this demo by visualizing
our results
in a new feature available on google
maps platform the open source database
library deck gl
with a bigquery connector provided by
cardo so we now have a clear picture of
where the built environment is changing
and where to focus next for our work on
flood risks
in summary
no wrangling data no need to manage
infrastructure just actionable insights
incredibly quickly
we can't wait to see what you'll do with
earth engine's new integration with
google cloud
and with that i'll pass it back to
aperno
thank you joel
it's incredible to see how our customers
can use our sustainable technologies to
address climate change now
i'm really inspired by all the things
we've talked about today and thinking
about how you're going to lead your
companies into the future that's super
exciting
no pressure but it's really up to you
we've invested millions in the developer
community over the last five years and
will continue to invest in the coming
years
and orrs as proof of that i understand
you have some additional news to share
today
absolutely i'm really excited to
announce today our new developer
community program called google cloud
innovators
i want to welcome and introduce our
first group of leaders who are driving
meaningful impact in the industry and
their communities so take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is so exciting
yeah through this program we'll give
developers access to early technology
previews and google engineers
will recognize the expertise of our
community influencers by promoting their
contributions and we will work closely
with them to solve the toughest problems
so we're excited to come together with
this group of innovators join us at
cloud.google.com
innovators so cool i've been waiting for
this all this time
community is extremely important for
companies to create that much needed
human connection with developers
and we hope that this gives you a window
into the motivation that you all give
google to build cloud products and
services that developers love
and we look forward to partnering with
you to become the greatest tech
companies in your industries remember to
join us next at the live developer q a
session and also tomorrow at community
day enjoy the rest of the show
thanks everyone
[Music]
you